good morning millennials welcome back to
the toast happy Wednesday it is hump day
a great day here at the toast because
although we are you know
transatlantically separated Jax and I
are humping each other
virtually today it's a virtual hump
it's so good which is so 20 20. oh God
yeah virtual hugs to everyone yeah never
mind
NVM never mind I'll just be Humphrey
today how are you I'll just see Dan
Humphrey
you're you are Dan um no I'm not that's
like actually I would never yeah who do
you think you are in Gossip Girl like
I'm definitely dorota you are dorota
I think I am I'm Blair let's get real
I'm a Blair you're either like a Blair
Serena or a Jenny I feel like I'm kind
of like a Georgina actually you're not
really all I know is I'm not a Vanessa
no
um
hey sexy shirt I'm Lily I keep trying to
call you sexy I'm Lily except the
compliment I'm Lily because I got I have
your answer
okay you I saw a video of you this
morning taking care of Harry wearing a
sexy form-fitting shirt that made you
look so sexy like your breasts looked
large and perky your belly was bumping
like why'd you change you looked great
I'm wearing that shirt underneath but I
always have like I have the sweatshirt
around my waist it's just it's
comforting and you just never know how
things are gonna look on the camera yeah
so I don't want to do a whole show like
thinking I look one way seeing it
another way and you know I'd rather just
be my cozy self
that's why I try not to watch this show
I just feel like what I look like on
camera to other people is really none of
my you watch the show every day I I
don't watch it every day but a lot of
days I will recap listen and like maybe
see what we need to clip but I don't
watch it like I pull it up on YouTube
and then I'm on my phone like it's in
this little square at the top I don't
really look at myself got it I don't
mind the YouTube it's really the reals
there's something about like the way
that the reels crop and I just hate how
I look so I'm like I'm not taking any
chances do you want us to start zooming
out on the reels there's only so much we
could zoom out I tried that once like
the the frame is the frame I don't know
what it is it's like how on Microsoft
Word like if you drag a photo to make it
bigger without changing like
if you change the ratio yes it's a
warped fun house and I just can't have
that I want to enjoy our reels I want
gen Z to love me they do as they do so
sweatshirt it is
it's Wednesday which means we have a
fabulous show because we have deer
toasters and we actually have an update
from a pretty popular deer toasters that
uh I think it was maybe last year I
don't know any concept of time it could
have been 2007. for Claudia everything
is three to four months ago
or or like 2015. I really yeah or three
to four years yeah I cannot concept like
visually concept concept is can you use
it as a verb conceive conceive whatever
um but that's also a great time to
mention if you loved your toasters as
much as we do on our patreon yesterday
we dropped a podcast full episode like
45 minutes of all dear toaster
submissions we had some really funny and
interesting conversations about you know
the intersectionality of chivalry and
feminism where do we land honestly I
don't know not you using the word
intersectionality it's kind of like one
of my favorite words but no you were
grasping for it yesterday but you didn't
no I found it on the podcast yesterday
and ever since I like realized that's
the word I've been looking for I feel
like sometimes I say like convergence or
like I just make some [__] up
intersection that's the word I'm always
looking the intersection is a known term
you know the intersection but
intersectionality yeah is much more vast
no I feel like it's kind of one of those
like buzz New Age words yeah like like
when someone says like the intersection
like I'm always Gonna Roll my eyes but
like it's kind of an amazing word yeah
take it back turdy I'm taking it back so
there's a new patreon if you don't get
enough of your deer toasters fixed today
which you will because we have a great
update and two really good submissions
um head over to patreon.com toast to
hear Jackson clock Doling out some you
know some wonderful advice coming for
Abby's neck yeah you're obsessed with
taking Abby down even though you've
already killed her no Abby like set the
she really opened the door for us to be
able to do your toasters but ever since
she opened the door I it's on my mission
to become bigger than her I know
I just when people say like you know
it's that'll be become like a colloquial
term like Dear Abby it's not even about
Abby it's just about like the concept of
giving advice
our thing is called the ear toasters
because of Dear Abby like you have to I
know you have to respect those who came
before you I'm taking Abby down
I don't know the deer toasters is only
like one
tenth of our show so it's not even like
we invest it's not like we do it every
day like Abby committed her life to
advice
she did I don't know if we could say the
same
I feel like I've committed my life to
bettering others lives yes yes I agree
and a base is a part of that
just can't she have her advice
I guess I'll let her Legacy remain
intact for today
she lives to see another day but who
knows after today's dear toasters right
right yeah
um so we've got a great show it's
Wednesday Jax is here Claude is here and
very soon Jackson Claude will be
together again yes tomorrow will be our
last show Miles and Miles AP
yes and it'll also just want to remind
everyone I feel like I can't say it
enough times there is no show on Friday
unless your patreon member will have a
pre-recorded episode with Ben and Claude
dropping on Fridays so you do own um
miss out on anything and then next week
yeah Jax and I are together but we also
we are missing episodes next week it is
the holiday of pesach Passover happy
Passover to all of our Jewish toasters
so we will be taking two days off next
week to celebrate you know the holiday
of matzah and freedom passing over it's
really the holiday of freedom is it yeah
the slaves were freed from in Egypt oh
right let my people go how does that
verse go
Moses was in Egypt's land let my people
go it's one of my favorite holidays and
my least favorite holidays because you
can't eat any bread which is for like
two weeks which is so annoying and it's
not just bread eight days brain so it's
like rice it's so much [__] that I love
and it's my favorite holiday because
there's so much singing there's a lot of
singing there's two nights of
festivities two nights of singing that
is mandatory yeah like is not completed
until you've sung and there are a lot of
really good Passover snacks
and really good workarounds you know
like you have french fries yeah potato
uh potato saving the day potato saves
the day I love a potato you know how I
feel about a baked potato
so many bangers that like I've known
like my whole life you know and I really
only sing them once a year and it's
crazy how like you know you never forget
them it's not like I practice them I
swear sure I swear I don't sure she goes
home I just practiced my mirror I just
practiced my solo what's my solo again
yeah if you are familiar with the Seder
you know festivities there's one
particular part of the prayer that is so
sickening it's so like it's really
harmonious and you know I love my family
because they've given me that part to
kind of lead and make your own
and make my own I'm really like put my
foot in and you do
and I do year after year year after year
she doesn't disappoint so it's it's a
good holiday coming up it's not Yom
Kippur where we have to fast so let's
just be grateful for that
yeah I'm I'm grateful I'm excited I'm
excited that you're coming Flamingo
toast it's like not saying at your house
I'm staying at Olivia's house this time
I know but I have Tesla so I can come
pick you up any day or time oh my God we
will no longer whenever in the past
you've lived in Florida what for nine
months
eight months uh and every time I've come
down there I've spent a significant
amount of time there probably like in
total maybe six or seven weeks
we have been prisoners we're stranded of
Jackie's home of Zach's schedule because
if Zach has the car for work like we're
not gonna take the car from him he has
to work like we have been prisoners we
like can't go to lunch we can't do any
of the fun things that we want to do we
can't do like a mooc bong fast food in
the car like nothing nothing and if we
and if we do it's like cut short oh I
need the car come home oh my God
prisoners and then it's like okay well
maybe we could borrow the Shapiro's car
but the Shapiro's literally have two
kids like Yay busy schedules never
available and their car is huge like
right and when it is available we have
to drive the bus they literally drive a
school bus the biggest Jeep you've ever
seen in your goddamn life yeah so now
that I have Tesla it's gonna be a whole
different sort of trip you know what we
are we're just two girls with with
freedom
Freedom Is A Highway
oh I was gonna do freedom I won't let
you down freedom I will not give you a
freedom I think mine's just like a
little more pertinent on the nose it's
about driving it's a little more on the
nose eye gray and so even though you're
not staying with me it'll feel like
there's no distance between us because I
have Tesla
so it won't feel like we're miles apart
oh
I wanna do
is be with turdy Lou
there's nothing we can't do
I should make a really great car
playlist for us filled with all the
songs we love to sing virtually toast
tunes and then we'll patreon oh and you
know Tesla has karaoke which I now pay
for it right right like a big dope yeah
no not like a big dope I need all the
Tesla features I didn't get this [__]
cover nothing that's true you know what
I mean no I got a Tesla to say oh no
take your features keep that right right
keep your features I'm shy
I don't want features no karaoke no not
me I have to look at the road literally
how are the stories today
stories are storying I wouldn't say
there's like the big news I would say
it's four equally unimportant stories
with one important food news item
is it you know what I don't want to
spoil it I'm excited you can ask for a
clue no it's okay do you think you know
what story it is
food news I'm not sure but if you know
about this but it's extremely important
that you know is it a collab no
is it a new menu item
new variation on a beloved menu item
that makes it sound like small potatoes
but it's not it's big news is it a new
flavor of McFlurry yeah I might even
hear about it don't spoil what it is I
won't but yeah wow I meant to tell you
when I was in Lisbon and I ate
McDonald's 47 times because it was the
only food I liked
um how popular and prevalent on the menu
the big plant was I think the big plant
is like popping in international markets
I'm happy for the international
folks that toasters
they get to experience mcplan even
though I'm kind of like off of imitation
meat imitation meat
is that a pregnancy thing well it's it
has to do with pregnancy because it's
like I'm trying not to eat stuff that's
fake but like that stuff is crap no it's
really and I think it's made in a lab
just like anything else once in a while
you know if I'm at a burger joint and
everyone's having burgers and I get to
have an impossible like sure but as far
as like it being a replacement for other
protein like it's not for me it's not
it's not cutting it no it's just too
fake
and I keep it I keep it real dirty no
we're just not trying to have like fake
toxic energy in our lives no like I
don't deal with fake people why would
you deal with fake meat I don't know it
doesn't make sense it doesn't make sense
we're stopping that now yeah I'd rather
just have like a morning star veggie
burger like we're so like
anti-fraudulence like in our brand and
we really should carry that through to
all aspects of our lives our diet
included yeah
yeah that's why I only real food from
McDonald's well that's why you'll need
like real meat from McDonald's because
they have even though they have the
meats we should go to Arby's we
shouldn't go for the mukbang but it's
like the work what would the [__] would
we eat at Arby's
the meats
you can't eat meat and I would literally
never okay let's let's pull up the
Arby's menu
I've never had Arby's and I do know that
Arby's is one of the only fast food
franchises that has um curly fries curly
fries yeah so curly swirly fries I would
get curly swirly okay here Arby's Order
ahead okay see these sandwiches with
like their vagina looking Meats oh sorry
crispy juicy chicken the tender bites
that's what I would have oh they have a
chicken slider sandwich and I see this
looks fire flames they have crispy fish
wait sandwich look at the dessert they
have so many different types of cookies
apple turnover chocolate shakes
oh kids menu okay
oh my God they have pouches
kids menu is a chicken slider sandwich
which literally looks so good and then
the chicken nuggets meal I didn't know
they had chicken nuggets at Arby's I'll
go now yeah there's really nothing for
me except for a crispy fish sandwich
like how is that possible but um I'm not
gonna just like impose my preferences on
this whole business so I just don't know
I'll get like curly fries and the loaded
fries I don't know who would like all
right let's go mozzarella sticks oh wow
I don't know who like would think to
themselves okay let's go get fast food
should we get McDonald's should we get
Burger King should we get Wendy's or
should we get the roast beef gyro from
Arby's like who would think that people
would think that like and people are
allowed to think that turdy they are
they are gums people would look at that
whole menu and they would say who would
get chicken fingers at a place like this
when there's such an assortment well
anyone who says that is so toxic you
don't need that kind of energy in your
life and that's how they feel about you
the gyro lovers it's actually so true
and they don't even have gyro at
McDonald's or Burger King so like
there's only one place to go and it's
Arby's let's talk about gyro and people
who pronounce it Hiro
I don't know them do you know that
that's like a common pronunciation is
that a proper president I don't know I
don't know but like we're not in Greece
this is America okay I have a question
what if you want a gyro hero
that would that great question then you
would say hi I would like a hero hero
it's confusing
no it's a fire point you bring up yeah a
case closed
I guess you'd have to break it up you'd
say I had like the hito please and
they're like would you like that on a
bun or a hero and then you would say
hero just to like you know for clarity
purposes you say I need a hero I'm
looking out for a Hero
[Music]
yeah that's what you would say
love a hero
all kinds of Heroes what's wrong with
the hero uh food hero yeah no I'm I'm
all for her like you know people who do
Brave things
of a gyro here
um no
no and then a hero comes along
with the strength to carry on
and you cast your fears that's one of my
favorite Mariah Carey songs and in my
opinion one of the more underrated ones
it's so good it's so beautiful hero is
such a great word
and on the one hand I feel like it's not
used enough but on the other hand I'm
glad because it should be used so
sparingly so that it maintains its
pristine meaning we need to preserve the
word hero I completely agree I'm glad it
hasn't been overused to the point where
it means nothing anymore yeah I can see
like on Tick Tock being like Oh my God
that lip gloss is a slay you're a hero
no by the way for sure I hope that never
happened but I'm also not here for the
feminization you know she's a heroine no
a woman could be a hero too oh
I feel like you would have the opposite
tape
why like there's word for man and
there's word for woman
no because to be honest when you look at
the words hero and heroin like hero
feels stronger well because also heroin
is a drug right right so true and I
think it's literally spelled the same
way no
female Hero has an e at the end
doesn't heroin the drug too no okay
I just I know like why why it just makes
you know what it makes me feel stupid
like if I do something Brave like I
don't want the special word like I want
the word that everyone uses and that's
hero and you think it should be a gender
fluid word if I rescue a cat from a tree
and put my own life at risk I'm a hero
[__] do not go and call me a heroine
also because I feel like when I think
about a heroine I think of like you know
some of the books that I read like
historical fiction and like this heroine
who's just like
she's doing really good stuff for sure
she's like low-key irresponsible no no
she's good like it's all good but if a
man were doing those things I don't know
if we call him a hero like I feel like
the bar is higher for hero and the bar
is a little lower for heroin you know
what that's an excellent take I agree as
well that's now that I'm talking through
it that's right what I'm feeling like so
I actually agree with you I want to be a
hero I I would like to be a hero and
then I'd like to eat a hero
a hero hero
bring it back no ahiro hero so have you
ever had gyro that should be your next
Tick Tock video
where can I get kosher gyro oh I'm sure
you could get kosher gyro at like an
Israeli restaurant oh actually
definitely like for sure
and like what is try no such a good
question it's like beef that's like
cooked differently
it's like hard no is it supposed to be
hard or that's bad gyro
I don't know and it's like where is the
line between gyro and jerky no no I
don't think your gyro is supposed to be
jerky I think that's like oh I had that
gyro jerk no because I think like you
can get your gyro crispy you could get
crispy gyro but that's yeah crispy like
regular gyro should be a little juicy
wow I just want to say when you Google
gyro the first thing that comes up is
arbys.com and it says this search may
also be relevant to Gyro's Arby
it's just because it's listening to us
okay Gyros is a meat cooked on a
vertical rotisserie sounds like Shawarma
sounds like shwarma then sliced and
served wrapped her stuff in a pita bread
wait
Google Now what's the difference between
gyro and Shawarma maybe it's just a
different word for it right there's a
Mexican Cuisine
no like maybe in different places salsa
is salsa and in other countries it's
like bruschetta yeah but like I think
Gyro in is Greek so in Greece they call
it gyro and Israel they call it Shawarma
by the way so the biggest difference is
in their flavor profiles so I think at
its core in terms of like what it is and
how it's cooked it's the same but Gyros
have like that Greek fresh taste and
shawarmas have the more Middle Eastern
spicy complex flavor got it so it's
about the spices
yeah it's about the spices it's always
about the spices yeah spices could spice
anything up and power to the world spice
up your life every boy and every girl
spice up your life people of the world
spice up your life
people are gonna complain there's too
much singing today but you guys like
don't waste your your keystrokes because
we're not listening stop
we're not listening and you know what
there's not one waste your keystrokes
give us that engagement yeah give us the
engagement but there's not one part of
that criticism that even remotely
touches me like that I absorb in the
least like no I think that's what sets
us apart from Abby does Abby sing
she wishes
so true no that's not a valid criticism
I rebuke no like I'm sure it's valid for
you like you didn't like the singing
part of this episode but like we love it
so that trumps your dislike
I don't even want to add anything
because what you said was so perfect
we love it
bringing it back full circle to
McDonald's mcplant that's how this
conversation started got it so we're not
we're saying no to fake
yes to real we're stopping the negative
self-talk and we're dressing like a
[__] and we're singing and we're
quoting ourselves
who else
if not us who's gonna Quote us
Oh I thought you're gonna say it's not
us who are we gonna quote both that's
what I meant the first time and then I'm
like but then also who else is going to
quote us if not us it's so true like
sorry we're out here preserving our
Legacy so that Abby doesn't come back
from the dead and trying to come for
Claudia's neck right
so we've got a great show I think it's
time to dive in because we also have
deer toasters and it's just it's a great
day to be a toaster Tis so without
further Ado here are the fast five
stories that you need to know today
and today's episode is brought to you by
a new sponsor that we're really excited
about Topgolf it's golf it's not golf
it's Topgolf so uh Jackie and I had the
distinct privilege of visiting the
Topgolf in Nashville was that last year
two years ago two years ago oh my God we
had the best night out
um it was a girls trip and we spent the
whole Friday night at Topgolf the food
was so good
um and we had so much fun playing golf
even though we're not like huge golf
girls it was really the perfect spot for
a girls night and I think that kind of
uh surprised us a little bit because
again we're not like super into golf but
the Vibes were Immaculate and the golf
was so fun like we got so competitive we
really did everyone played like there's
a leaderboard I did win I feel like
that's really important like every time
we do this ad to remind you guys that I
won when we played top golf but really
anyone can win if you're clearly skilled
enough like me yeah it was also just
like a great place to meet because we
were all girls and a bunch of us were
single like it was a great place to meet
people it was so much fun
um and so obviously they have a lot of
stuff that makes them go off you know
they've got the clubs the balls the t's
the turf but they also have a bunch of
stuff that's not golf like great music
giant targets giant TVs handcrafted food
and beverage menus it's so much fun so
if you don't play golf it doesn't matter
because everyone can play Topgolf even
if you can't swing a club the food and
beverages are so good it's the only
place where you can play around and then
order another it's also super
comfortable they have all the fun of
outside but with the Comforts of inside
they have comfortable heated bays in the
winter and cooled bays in the summer we
went when it was hot and we were not hot
at all they had you know real
temperature regulation which is somebody
very temperature focused I really
appreciate it
um so it's golf it's not golf it's
Topgolf download the app book a bay and
come play around today's episode is also
brought to you by the perfect bar so if
you're looking for a protein bar that
actually tastes good look no further
then perfect bar with their lineup of
fresh from the fridge protein bars
perfect bar is exactly what you and your
family need so it's made with freshly
ground nut butter organic honey and 20
organic superfoods perfect bar has a
variety of products like protein bars
little snack size bars that are also
good and good for you and you'll be sure
to find something you love the texture
of the bar is like a cookie dough
texture it's creamy and full of flavor
um and now they come in a snack size
which is packed with six grams of
proteins and 150 calories so a little
goes a long way
um that's a perfect size to throw in
your purse like you keep it in the
fridge because the ingredients contain
no artificial preservatives and they're
made with whole food ingredients so you
store it in the fridge and then while
you're leaving for the day if you're
going to the gym or you just have a long
day of meetings throw it in your purse
you'll avoid that like crash it'll keep
you full it'll keep you up and Adam
George McFadden
um and if you aren't convinced already
they also have uh non-GMO project
verification they're gluten-free soy
free low GI and kosher Happy Passover
perfect bar knows that it'll be Love At
First Bite so for a limited time they're
offering you a chance to try their
refrigerated protein bars for free
here's how it works sign up for email or
text upload a picture of your receipt
from your local grocery store and
they'll reimburse you for the cost of
one bar it'll go directly into your
venmo or PayPal account all you have to
do is go to perfect snacks.com toast to
get a free perfect bar today that's
perfect snacks.com toast to get a free
perfect bar today happy snacking thank
you Claudia yeah welcome Jackie our
first story Kelly Ripa is on the cover
of variety this month talking about
being a power woman of 2023 she is
talking about her career and she's
talking about substantial
things she said that live Executives at
live banished her to a Janitor's Closet
instead of an office during her early
years on the show Kelly Ripa claims the
executive Spanish sugar janitors closet
instead of giving her an office during
her early years on the morning show the
longtime co-host submitted in a new
interview that she had known how
difficult that had she known how
difficult her first three seasons would
have been she might not have taken the
gig in the first place she said it was
the strangest experience I've ever had
in my life I was told that I couldn't
have an office she also said that she
was not given maternity leave vacation
time or a wardrobe budget when she
joined live in 2001. she said it didn't
make a whole lot of sense especially
because there were empty offices that I
could have easily occupied she said when
she asked about moving one to to one of
the available rooms producers told her
they were reserved for executives
visiting from the West Coast she said it
was after my fourth year that they
finally cleaned out the closet and put a
desk in there for me and so I was
working in the Janitor's Closet with a
desk so that I could have a place to put
things however after original host Regis
left the show in 2011 Kelly assumed she
would finally get an actual office only
to be snubbed once again for her
incoming male counterpart Michael
Strahan they said oh no we're saving
that and I said saving it for what and
they go well for when the new guy comes
and I looked at them and I said I am the
new guy I just moved my things I forced
my way into the office because because I
couldn't understand how I would still be
in the Janitor's Closet and somebody
knew would come in and get the office
she said the experience was just another
reminder to Kelly that female anchors
were viewed as Sidekicks rather than the
main Talent she said it was like
watching the same movie all over again
all of those offices that were not
available to me were suddenly made
available with walls knocked down to
make them twice as big it was
fascinating for me to watch the need to
make the new guy comfortable and
respected but I couldn't use those
offices I had to use the broom closet
she said not only that but she was not
given her own bathroom and had to share
a public restroom with the live studio
audience despite the male co-anchors
having their own stall she said picture
this we have a studio audience like 250
people and I have to queue up she noted
that it was extraordinarily exhausting
tap to wait in line while she was
pregnant
okay I'm not giving her maternity leave
is like the craziest thing I've ever
heard and like grounds for
lawsuits
um that's also what we were just talking
about like how do you host a live show
and go on maternity leave a daily live
where you are 50 of the show there's no
that's us not that like we're live with
Regis and Kelly we're obviously so much
bigger but uh 100
she really I guess is a good example to
look at and there's the answer she
didn't have maternity leave no but she's
not a good example to look at because
she's an employee of like a major
company and legally companies like that
have to provide
some sort of maternity I don't know I
don't know what the law is I don't think
that they have to
well I I find a lot of what she says
really interesting and I think the
maternity leave thing is like beyond
disgusting but I don't necessarily agree
with her how it's like women are women
anchors are viewed as Sidekicks no
actually she was just a part of a show
where the template was it was regis's
show and now and and the women were
Sidekicks and now it's Kelly show and
the men are Sidekicks like she has a
rotating crew of people who come in
every few years and then she has all
these guests like it's Kelly's show now
yes before it was regis's show and Kelly
when it was regis's show I think like
yeah that what she you know she sat and
didn't have an office and sat in the
Janitor's Closet but then when it when
Regis left and Mike didn't give her was
getting the Regis treatment and it's
like no you were the sidekick yeah and
she interpreted that to be because he is
male and she is female that he was
getting the male treatment not the maybe
maybe that's what the networks maybe
that's what the Network's goal was like
maybe their intention wasn't to make it
like the Kelly show it was have to to
continue having Kelly as that sort of
because that's what the show's format
was for many years like Kathy Lee and
Regis like it was a man it was really
like the man show with like a female
kind of Vanna White co-hosty Vibe yeah
but Kelly really you know what she
really did make it her own yeah but they
also changed the name to Live with Kelly
and Michael and I think that if they
meant for it to be Michael's show it
would have been Michael and Kelly no
that's true
I think there was probably a lot of
confusion at that time I think Kelly had
been waiting 10 years to take regis's
spot whenever that time came and I'm
sure the network saw a little
differently so I understand how there
was friction we also know that region
Kelly did not have a good relationship
so it's very possible that that
um
toxicity
was kind of the environment of the show
too like the people who worked for Regis
were team Regis yeah yeah but I mean
when you look at it at a whole like
she's been doing the show now for 22
years like it's still top of the rating
she sells so much energy like she really
is a staple in everyone's mourning like
I feel like she really fought her way
there yeah and she obviously took her
what is the phrase
where you take your
lemons no
like when you
to it to mean like
make the most of what you get no no
where it's kind of like hazing like you
take what your licks I don't know pay
your dues sure but there's a take your
phrase as well but she paid her dues and
you know she didn't get the starter
treatment for 23 years yeah no that's
it's actually really shocking yeah it's
also a nice change of pace to read
something from Kelly that actually has
substance and it's not just about how
many times you know Mark Consuelos eats
her ass a month yeah well they do have
crazy face time sex apparently not in
this interview but that's the other
headline about Kelly this week get you a
girl who could do both
get you a girl who could do both
preferably more of the former and less
of the latter but sure yeah but I think
also it's I feel like she if she had to
you know everyone sees their own career
in like their own troubles differently
than how the world sees them like just
look at Kelly and I'm like she's Kelly
She's Every Morning like yeah she's at
the top of the industry but I feel like
for Kelly I feel like she might have
like a hard time getting taken seriously
a little bit and so she does those like
Little People magazine Hello magazine
pieces of crap because like that's
what's available to her but like variety
gave her power of women like she got
respect she gave a respectful interview
that's actually so true wait are we
flipping this Kelly's mindless news on
its head right now like you're right
people really Kelly Ripa like is a maven
of talk television and she's an OG and
she was like she really brought her show
into the 21st century like that Regis
show was like so old school and she kind
of gets like no respect no no like when
you think of like
female Titans of Television you don't
think of her and you should
no you're a hundred percent right and I
think that's probably something that she
struggles with
being taken seriously like even you know
when you first read this thing I like
rolled my eyes like my cheese on the
cover of variety but like she's exactly
the type of person who should be on the
cover of variety yeah why not Kelly
no she's really the show is
a major stop like for every major
celebrity and press tour yeah
shows get canceled all the time like
it's so scary especially talk shows yeah
to get viewers to retain viewers to
compete in that space like that morning
programming is so we've seen good
morning we saw more yeah we know how
hard it could be right and it really is
like the cycle even people who you think
are gonna slay the house down Meredith
Vieira Kris Jenner Bethany it doesn't
work out yeah
so
I think we need to put a little more
respect on her name I agree she like
fought her way out of the Janitor's
Closet literally huh
I'm seeing I'm seeing Kelly through a
whole new lens that's what a great
interview could do you're so right but
also a great podcast discussion but it's
also what the right platform like you
know being on variety will give you that
sort of reputability and maybe if we
read her book yeah we would feel even
more so
this way yeah
but I'm reading so slowly these days me
too it took me three weeks to finish my
last book which was decent
um I'm dying to read paris's book but I
have to start the redheads book we
record next week like I'm booked and
busy literally and busy that's a good
name for a reading podcast booked and
busy what about for your book club
we are so busy and you're booked
obviously once a month
I like it you could say you guys Jackie
came up with a really good name yeah
another way for me to like bring up no
you could say oh hey you say I have the
name for the book club like don't even
mention me because I feel like that'll
take away actually like a lot of members
of my book club listen to the podcast so
they'll see like the the natural or
authentic Genesis of the name okay I
think they'll like that yeah yeah yeah
you kind of had to be here and luckily
you all were here for that yeah thank
God we record this
my cards are good okay we're still
recording thank God are you ready for
our next story which is some more TV
news yes
Bachelor Creator Mike Fleiss is exiting
the franchise after 21 years
oh wow like Place announced the news on
Tuesday in a statement congratulating
season 27 lead Zack shallcross and his
new fiance who by the way this is who
won the show Katie bigger on there yeah
I saw a clip of them talking and it was
really really special I saw a photo like
a headline and a photo of their proposal
with like a get the Deets on the ring oh
I for no I watched on like a tick tock
GMA did like they gave them placards and
it was like who is the later sleeper you
know and these people like so know
nothing about each other it was painful
it was not do you think that they are in
love and and will last I don't I
actually based on what I got from them
and based on what people have said it's
like Zach is a robot he's so vanilla and
you know what she's like a really kind
of beautiful simple girl I actually
think it could work I really like want
them to work I'm like in the mood for a
bachelor
yeah and a little Redemption like it
would take a lot for me to start
watching again and the shows would have
to be like cut down to like one hour
45 minutes yeah like I can't do two
hours
um
but I don't know they're making changes
I can't believe Mike slice is leaving
like that is that'd be like Andy leaving
Bravo it's it's so Monumental and I
think it's a real indicator that the
show is on its last like I mean tell me
tell me this is not an indicator ready I
was mind blown I came across that girl
we were talking about last week who made
it to the top four who was Jewish I came
across her Instagram and she was so oh
no I came across yeah her Instagram and
she did this like cute get ready with me
so I went to her page guess how many
followers she has after being on the top
four less than fifty thousand oh no no
no no no oh
what 120. yeah that's low
The Bachelor himself I was looking at
his
like is so low I think it's less than
that for guys it was always like less I
remember 171. if you made it to the top
four like I remember back with like Nick
vials season a lot of those girls ended
up after the season reaching a million
followers so to be a top four and to be
a favorite everyone loves this girl
Arielle
um and to not even crack 200 I think
that's like a huge indicator of how much
of the the show's audience has fallen
off yeah the girl who won his 218.
that's crazy I remembered distinctly
like
The Raven Gates Rachel Lindsay of course
they would some they would be really
near a million Vanessa they all were in
like eight nine hundred thousand and
eventually they hit a million I wonder
what they have on Tick Tock maybe like
because these girls are that's a good
question
like because yeah like they're just
younger girls they're younger girls and
I think younger girls are watching and
they gravitate towards following people
on Tick Tock now
that's a good uh she has 40 000 on Tick
Tock um
what is Zach have or Katie
how do you spell Zach what's his last
name shall cross
he shall cross
I don't know if this is his page but he
has one post with six thousand followers
okay yeah no it's not doing what it was
but I don't think my place leaving means
that it's over I'm surprised Mike place
has been around this long without
getting canceled he's so probably like
we have heard crazy stories yeah like
he's just like textbook like the show
unreal like yeah they get their
inspiration from Mike Fleiss and his
ways so I think he's quitting while he's
ahead and the the franchise is slowing
down so it's a good time to go I can't
believe he lasted this long without like
actually having a major Scandal canceled
yeah but see that's how you like that's
why it is like unreal like it's so he's
so powerful like you know contestants
would never speak out against him
producers whatever he's the almighty
being like if you want a career if you
want to go on Dancing With the Stars I
remember what he did to Caitlin Bristow
like yeah he could blackball you in a
second yeah I also think some
contestants don't interface with him
that much like I feel like his power
like just her leads comes from on high
and then like he that culture like
disseminates from him to like top
producers and then like the producers
produce but it all kind of spreads down
there's no one person to blame it on you
know what I mean yeah but it starts from
the top yeah and he is the top so if
there's a toxic culture at The Bachelor
like it comes from him I can't believe
he's leaving yeah so he put out a
statement saying first and foremost
congratulations are in order for Zach
and Katie I wish them a long and happy
life together I want to thank WBTV and
ABC for 21 extraordinary years they
found the perfect creative team for me
to entrust The Bachelor franchise and
keep this lightning in a bottle bold and
moving forward he will be replaced by
new showrunners Jason Ehrlich Claire
Freeland and Bennett grabner who all
have lengthy ties to the show so I think
it's just people getting promoted yeah I
mean if they really wanted to shake
things up and compete with like the love
is blinds love Island they would bring
in like a whole new creative team it
sounds like it's just gonna be more of
the same watered-down episodes until the
show eventually ends yeah but I think
their ratings I guess as far as they're
not what they once were but it they're
still got million in the middle you know
what I mean like their ratings are still
enough for advertisers and yeah all that
I think I wonder better to like bring in
one new replacement who could
freshen things up but it sounds like
they don't want to freshen things up
like they think their formula works and
maybe it works for them it just doesn't
work for you and I turdy okay wait so in
terms of ratings this season averaged
0.81 that's 800 000 people in that demo
in the 18 to 49 demographic which is key
that's low
that is low hold on I feel like I'm not
reading that right it's impossible to
read ratings oh my god with the decibels
just tell me how many people watch
literally
literally I cannot read this
oh okay wait so explain okay so yes so
the episode that was on literally two
days ago in the 18 to 49 demo 0.63
but they had 3.4 million viewers how
does that make sense
who else who else is 18 to 49 you know
well 49 and up would be the majority of
viewers there's just so many people well
it says 3.4 million viewers you're right
which is still for a cable Show
excellent yeah but maybe it's like 0.63
households but then they account for
like a number of people per house it's
all fraudulent I really don't understand
ratings ratings are fraudulent well
in March or and like unless you record
the bachelor so I'm part of that last
week they variety wrote an article The
Bachelor hits multi-platform ratings
high with their season 27 Premiere so it
had a 2.39 rating which I believe is 2.3
million
okay
and that was a outperformance of the
show's prior season
hmm
well that's good yeah
see
yeah it's still it's still considered
good ratings like when you think about
how many people watch like shows on
Bravo they're lucky if they hit like a
million but this is like basic cable
that that's right right something else
but yeah
okay are you ready for our next story
yeah
Tristan Thompson buys a mansion three
houses down from his ex Chloe Kardashian
yeah Tristan purchased a home just Three
Doors Down from his ex-girlfriend Chloe
with whom he shares two children an
aerial photo obtained by Page Six the
NBA player's new mansion can be seen
within walking distance from the reality
star estate in Hidden Hills he signed
the deed for the 12.5 million dollar
house in December 2022.
that is last December okay
last Christmas he bought this new house
I don't know why I feel like Tristan
like doesn't have nearly enough money to
live in the same neighborhood because
he's not a great basketball player so
I'm just looking up what his salary okay
his oh salary let's see what his
contracts were also his house like from
the aerial photos his house looks bigger
than Chloe's
like it's huge so in 2021
when he was on the Kings his salary was
uh one year six six million dollars
that's pretty good and then he I guess
got moved to the Bulls and he got a
million dollars
and then prior to that wow actually I
take it back what I said uh excuse me
this can't be right
what is Tim Thompson
okay from his he started his career on
the Cavaliers that's where we met him
remember yeah 2011 to 2014 and Cleveland
he got 16 million dollars in those three
years okay then he signed another
contract with Cleveland for another four
years five years excuse me 82 million
dollars
which he which he literally he played
with them the full contract so he got
everything and then in 2020 for a one
year he went to uh
two years excuse me he went to what's
that little Irish thing the Celtics
Celtics 10 million excuse me 20 million
dollars well I take it back wow I don't
know why Ben always said he's like not a
good basketball player but what the [__]
does Ben know I think he's not like
Michael Jordan but like Michael Jordan
slash Kobe Bryant LeBron LeBron they
make hundreds of million dollars and
like but he's a good enough basketball
player to like be on the court and like
that's what you make when you're like
actually a playing NBA player that's
literally crazy to me crazy and I think
people just like to clown on him so even
if he was skilled like we wouldn't know
about it but that is crazy and okay take
it back he can certainly afford he can
certainly afford and he bought a really
nice house and even though I don't want
him and Chloe to be back together I
don't know if they are back together I
don't care I personally think this is so
nice for their kids for the kids of
course but people read this headline and
they're like he's stalking Chloe get
away from Chloe like and that they think
it's like a bad thing even when Kanye
did it like I didn't think that that was
a bad thing I think it's the best
possible case scenario for children with
separated parents and by the way I'm
sure he didn't spell spend 12 million
dollars on a house without getting
Chloe's blessing
yeah yeah it's so like you know grovely
up her ass like yeah but I think he
wouldn't do anything to make her mad I
mean he does a lot of things to make her
mad well of course of course but when
he's in his groveling phase like he's
such a on the show he's like I just want
to like earn your respect back earn your
trust back yeah shut up shut up why
don't you just keep your dick in your
pants and everyone will respect and
trust you literally this house is so
nice Claudia I think it's so nice like
I'm never gonna you know be mad I I
never want these two to ever be together
ever again but that doesn't mean that
like now they have two kids together
Tristan has other kids he needs like a
nice house for all his kids and to live
you know next door to your half siblings
is lovely yeah it's really nice so it's
nice I'm not gonna Cloud on him me
neither
are you ready for our next story some
unlikely fashion news unlikely fashion
news
succession fans are going wild for the
ludicrously capacious Burberry tote that
was mocked in the HBO show and now
everybody wants one so when we did our
session recap we talked about how Tom
mocked Greg's dates big ass Burberry
tote and it turns out people were
influenced the search for Burberry tote
has increased 300 percent since the
episode aired
wow I mean they you know what they
weren't messes necessarily making fun of
like the brand or the style of the bag
merely the size
um like he said it was so big it would
be slid across the floor in a bank
robbery
um which is so funny and you know what
like good on Burberry you know taking a
negative and look what happened yeah
it's not a great look for Burberry
because even though yes it's it's
popularity like they do Pride themselves
on being like a very serious brand and
like an elite uh like shiv should be
well shiv should be wearing the bag not
this interloper right who was like
widely considered by everyone as like a
poor person at the rich person's party
yeah just like to associate that with
Burberry it was a choice it was a it was
a choice and I actually it's not the
choice that I would have made thought to
make well I think it's so you know
obvious to do like Michael Kors or coach
no like even like Louis Vuitton yeah
because these are like wear like an LV
bag right because these are like these
aren't rich people these are like one
percent Next Level yeah who would never
be caught dead wearing a Gucci bag um
it's like maybe airmaze but that's it
yeah air maze is kosher I would have
even thought like Burberry in some
respects would been because there
actually are like you know more like
muted the very gaudy label first brand
rich people would never be caught dead
wearing that yeah
so they actually could have used
anything you're right and Burberry isn't
even Burberry actually can be like a
very muted understated like like
tasteful tasteful brand yeah I agree so
it's surprising but you know what I
actually I don't know what this says
about me but I like the bag I feel like
they actually should have done like one
of those Louis Vuitton never Falls yes
because it's so big first of all it's so
commercial like a commercial pedestrian
everyone has that bag yeah and it might
have been like a little bit more on the
nose yeah
because this has been so bad but it is
the size of it you know
yeah but I guess what they were saying
was that like it wasn't even that big
but this is huge yeah it wasn't even
that big and yet it was too big it's a
hilarious uh Saga and I enjoy to see you
know looking forward to see what happens
what happens next yeah agreed but for
now the bag is doing well good good good
good and now it's time for our fifth and
final much anticipated and hyped up
story McDonald's drops a new McFlurry
flavor let me think
because they have Eminem and Oreo right
that's it and do they have Reese's
sometimes that's what I was just
thinking sometimes I feel like it's a
seasonal Edition yeah
so that means they go candy candy is
their their theme or not candy like a
it's like a collab with like an Oreo
um I would love for them to do like a
snack Wells devil food but two randoms
two random like this isn't meant to be
like a a capsule thing it's like amazing
what is the item what is the menu need
to be balanced
something like sweet like sugary
yeah like sour watermelon or something
oh freaky no what's a classic flavor for
what is a McFlurry really
a Sunday
no
uh milkshake yes a sweet milkshake okay
I don't know just tell my strawberry
shortcake
ew no like a strawberry milkshake is so
good and the new flavor is Strawberry
Shortcake which features their signature
creamy vanilla soft serve strawberry
flavored clusters and a crispy buttery
shortbread cookies I'm sorry but that
sounds really good if that's what you're
into that day like either you want
chocolate milkshake or yeah I get it or
strawberry yeah yeah yeah
yeah and Oreo is actually like black and
white because it has the cream and the
yeah and M M McFlurries should be taken
off the market
I don't agree because M M's should not
be in ice cream because M Ms should not
get so cold that they're so hard and
then when you're having the soft ice
cream and you have these tooth breaking
items you know where I actually disagree
you know where everyone should be Eminem
should be in popcorn where they get
really hot and they melt a little and
they just sort of blend into the popcorn
it's so delicious I think they're both
good I actually when I get like tasty to
light I will often get mini M M's I like
when they get hard it's like a crunchy
little snack it's soft it's like a
[__] jawbreaker I like it I like it
no because you're gonna be starving no
because I like it it's what you said
because I like it
no because I hate it
cold literally ice cold
um okay Strawberry Shortcake not for me
but there's definitely a market for this
um and it does make sense thematically
yes there definitely was a hole in the
menu that I didn't see there's a hole in
the menu yeah there was but I think
about enough people talk about the pies
from McDonald's because I only had one
for the first time a few years ago not a
few years ago sorry it was last year
um and actually tried it on the patreon
for the first time when I was in Vegas
because I ordered a McFlurry and of
course on ubereats the machine was
broken so he's like I got you a pie
because you know you paid for dessert I
was like okay it was like this
strawberry pie when I tell you it was so
good I dropped it on the floor and I
kept eating it it was so [__] good
well that's a really good endorsement
yeah so good even tastes good with floor
on it yeah
so it will be available starting April
12th um maybe you'll still be here we
could move bomb it oh yes that's what
the people need to see our view of the
new milkshake right we'll let you know
if it's I'm sure it's delicious by the
way like uh it sounds good yeah
um so those were the fast five stories
you certainly did not need to know them
um but have no fear it's Wednesday and
that means deer toasters is here our
weekly advice segment every Wednesday
where we you know how about some girlies
who are in need of Our advice if you
ever want to write in the email to write
in as dear toasters gmail.com try and
keep it brief you know need to know
information don't write us a whole
Magilla because we're not going to rate
it
um and dear toasters is brought to you
by liquid death by now you've probably
seen liquid death or maybe you've heard
us talk about their Mountain Water and
flavored sparkling water that look just
like tall boys or beers I actually drink
uh liquid death quite frequently on the
toast a lot of people think I'm drinking
beer in the morning no it's sparkling
water sometimes it's flavored sometimes
it's the uh the lime sometimes it's the
the plain not only does liquid death
taste good and it's so hydrating and
wonderful but you look so cool drinking
it yeah it's like is that girl having a
beer this morning is she having a beer
Pregnant and So now these insane tall
boys from liquid death are actually
their new healthy Iced Teas so all of
the new Iced Teas
um are so delicious they come in three
flavors Grim leafer rest in Peach and
armless Palmer
um they're really good I actually am not
even like a huge iced tea girl but the
Grim leafer is so good it's delicious
and again it's just in a fun packaging
you know people think Jackie's over here
getting wasted but she's actually just
sipping on a nice iced tea and I'm just
looking like hardcore we have the rest
in peaches here we've been tearing
through them and they're so delightful
on a warm day
um they're unlike other Iced Teas that
are loaded with sugar they're slightly
sweetened with six grams of Premium
agave and only 30 calories and they
provide a micro dose of 30 grams of
caffeine per tallboy they're also
enhanced with B vitamins so liquid
death's new Iced Teas are available now
with free shipping on Amazon and
retailers near you as an added bonus the
toast listeners get 20 off their first
liquid death apparel purchase available
exclusively at liquiddeath.com toast
exclusions May apply that's
liquiddeath.com toast
are you ready kids
aye aye turdy I can't hear you I I turdy
oh
dear Jackson turdy Lou love you girls
started listening during Jackie's
maternity leave and I haven't stopped
since I'm getting married in May and I'm
doing all of the pre-wedding things hair
extensions Nails tan Botox Etc but
here's my question I've never gotten any
injections in my lips but when I smile
really big which I'm assuming will
happen a lot on my wedding day you can
see all my gums I'm planning on getting
a lip flip exactly one month from my
wedding to solve this issue but again
this is something I haven't done before
do I experiment four weeks before the
big day or do I just look at my gums in
all of my wedding photos please help a
toaster with small lips I'm inclined to
say wait till after your wedding you've
went this long with your gummy smile and
it didn't bother you enough to do
something about it there's no
guaranteeing that you're gonna like how
you look and then on the off chance that
it's not what you want it to be all of
your wedding pictures are kind of like
ruined by this instead just like you'll
never regret looking like yourself do
you know what I mean I know I speak
French you want it yeah you should
change something that bothers you but
it's different than like having
something removed like you can easily
imagine but I don't know what a lip flip
is gonna do for you well here's the
question here's the question what do you
think looks worse your gummy smile or a
potentially weird looking upper lip I
think bad
uh plastic or bad injections or whatever
is worse than than God's
big gums how much time do we have can
you get a flip now and try it out
what about that I'm all for like doing
the most before your wedding because I
did the least before my wedding and I
hate my wedding photos not I'm not for
doing the unknown four weeks before your
wedding when you it didn't bother you
enough to do it any at any other time in
your life I'm kind of here for it
do it after but look like yourself like
it's it's much less risky to just look
like yourself the girl you know the girl
you love the girl your husband fell in
love with then to maybe show up looking
like some clown you also could show up
looking amazing but you could look crazy
I don't know lip lips are so routine and
they're really not are they out of major
I've never seen a person that I know
with one I'm sure that you have it's
like a step below lip filler like it's
just if you have like an upper lip that
curls up so what do they do I don't know
what they do but like it flips your lip
just like a little bit more up I've seen
a lot of people get it and it's like
really not a big deal
so much about it maybe I don't know I
think if you do like a ton of research I
don't know I'm kind of here for it I say
do it
I say wait okay well you have your
answer are you at Jack's are you a
Claude yeah sound off in the comments
what should this toaster do Jackson
clotter split they're headed for
Splitsville no but it's like
you yeah I don't know if that's helpful
to have both answers because you can
like listen to either one of us and and
just go forth you have our permission
either way technically
so that's good yeah you have a
permission either way technically and
the thing is either scenario you might
end up regretting doing it or not doing
it you know like maybe you do it after
your wedding and it looks so good and
you're like [__] I should have just done
it
I think the chances of the regret levels
will be higher if you do it and it
doesn't go well then the regret levels
of if you didn't do it and you do it
after and you're like oh I wish I had
done that for my wedding but like
it's better this amount of risk is
better in my opinion
you know if you want to be conservative
go with Jax
if you want to be kind of crazy go with
me I don't get crazy before a wedding
I don't know weddings are overrated it's
like not that big of a deal
I know you just have like some I have
one regrets yeah regrets she has a few
but then again not too few to mention
now shall we
I am always am
one
not getting my moles removed two
not getting my my chin surgery three not
like stopping eating one [__] thing
that was in my way like I just ate my
way up until my wedding day I didn't
give a [__] and in a way I'm like in awe
of how little I gave a [__] I actually
like have respect because you know no
matter who you are everyone wants to
look their best on their wedding day and
you know everybody you know cuts out you
know a few things here and there not me
[__] I was just coasting and now I look
back because I look so different and I'm
like annoyed but a part of me is like I
was so free like I really didn't give a
[__] yeah and you know what there's such
power in that I really actually believe
that like I had so much fun like I don't
know well that I was gonna say what's
four sorry I didn't have fun on my
wedding but I'm just talking about at
that time in my life like I didn't I I
wasn't self-conscious about how I looked
like I was really happy yeah and I
didn't let I think a lot of people when
they you know get to a higher weight
they let it start to like impact their
life their ability to live a full life
you know they stop going to things or
like they don't put themselves out there
because they feel subconscious which is
totally normal and I'm just in awe of
the way like I didn't give a [__]
like
and I'm sorry like that's [__] cool
like I I respect myself for that agreed
so there's there's you know Beauty in in
the in the chaos and then another regret
is like just not having fun at my
wedding I was so like
involved in the planning it's like [__]
you have a whole team of planners back
off yeah and even like you could be you
should be so involved in your wedding
planning but you have to on the day of
your wedding go tell everyone around you
do not bother me with one thing I don't
care if the venue is on fire don't tell
me about it this is not my problem this
is everyone else's problem and you need
to enjoy your day that's my advice for
brides yeah it's some of the most
amazing advice uh the bangy's on fire
call the fire department like figure it
out also like what am I supposed to do
am I right use deductive reasoning okay
the place is on fire should I a call
9-1-1 B tell this useless girl who's not
gonna help the bride or see
none of the above a yeah and you either
have a bridesmaid a wedding planner uh
someone on your team who is in charge of
things that day and it's not gonna be
you so let someone else decide where we
should have it instead of this burn down
venue yep
what about where you're sitting right
now
yep it's not on fire right
all right next up hey Jackson Claude
obsessed with both of you thanks so much
for giving us premium content every day
it truly gets me through some days
here's my dilemma I'm 29 and my hair has
been going gray since my early 20s I'm
at the point where my roots are almost
fully gray I've made so I've made as
much peace with it as I can because it's
genetic and there's really nothing else
I can do but it's still a big insecurity
of mine I get my I get my roots dyed
every six weeks to keep it looking like
my natural color my issue is that one of
my best friends always points out my
roots once they've grown in for like a
month or so and asks me when I'm getting
them done I don't think she does it to
be mean but it's like [__] I am aware
that it's grown out and she knows I go
to get it touched up frequently what
would you say to your friend to get her
to stop pointing out the Grays without
coming off like an insecure wench oh
also I know you have you guys have
perfect hair but have any of your
friends dealt with premature graying
what tips and tricks do they have any
advice would be so appreciated love you
girls sincerely a great girly on the
latter half I personally don't know
anyone who has dealt with early graying
so if anyone in the comments has
personally dealt with it or like has
good tips and tricks I feel like root
spray is like such an easy way to touch
up like you know before you see before
you have your appointment but you're
like going out to lunch root spray I've
heard is great
um but any comments who can help just
help this girl out with like the with
the aesthetic part but now with the
friend part yeah too yeah because
actually so funny like literally two
days ago Zach and I were sitting next to
each other he was like looking at my
hair funny he was like I was like what
and he was like I think you have some
Grays and I was like
oh it's not what I thought you were
gonna say and I know like I I've never
noticed them I think I was trying to
then see them but I also just put a lot
of product in my hair that was white so
I think it was it didn't bother me
though I would have been more interested
if I had grazed then insecure because
it's not something that like is a one of
my insecurities but clear for this
person it is and what a [__] [__]
your friend is it's like does she not
have one an insecurity or one thing that
like it's off about her not conventional
that she doesn't know how it feels to be
told like oh you're this is bad like she
must be so perfect and really because I
can't understand someone who would call
out someone else's flaw like I really
and it's not like you don't have eyes
yeah and I don't think this is a
situation where you need to like sit
down and and tell her I think it's a Tit
for Tat oh you have some hair growing in
oh thanks Rachel you got a big pimple on
your nose you're gonna do something
about that I know a great facialist okay
but that's also that comes off a little
um
sometimes the only way to make someone
see
themselves is to hold up a mirror
literally but like an eye for an eye in
the whole world is blind turdy good if
I'm blind everyone else should be I know
I'm just I'm trying to think how we
could be effective here because she's
also your friend no but she has hurt you
and she has all for revenge like you
hurt me I hurt you I know but you could
also hurt her by like
turning it around on her and being like
girl you think I don't know you know
that I touch up my roots every six weeks
like okay so you caught me on the one
day that my return and I do not need a
reminder I see myself in the mirror more
than you see me can you please shut the
[__] up like I would just put her in her
place just yeah maybe come at her come
at her not don't sit her down and be
like it really hurts my feelings come at
her yeah and like be a little aggressive
be a little aggressive about also like
you're the victim in the situation like
make her feel bad because there's
nothing worse than feeling like you did
something like the knowing that you did
something wrong that you heard someone
and you just have to sit there with your
bitchiness yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and
be like if it really if you really can't
help but say something then I guess I
won't see you until after I've had my
root touch-up appointment I'll see you
every six weeks yeah like what a [__]
[__] honestly
no I'm like mad well right back in what
are her flaws no her life is so perfect
and her face and her hair and her body's
so perfect that she starts she obviously
doesn't know how it feels to have
someone like call out your insecurities
because she has she's she's obviously
like a deeply insecure person because
really only miserable people do that
like I would never there's a difference
between calling it out when you think
like like maybe if you like okay if Ben
has like a pimple on his back he can't
see it so I have to tell him but it's
like your roots you have a mirror like
you you're there's no way you don't know
yeah but I don't know I I I saw him
cannot relate to someone who would do
who would call something out like that
that I actually think that it because
like I I would know how it feels to of
course you're told like there's
something awry that you clearly know
about so I actually think it must be
because she doesn't know how it feels to
have someone say that to her
so say it
no she doesn't know how it feels to have
someone like call out an insecurity
where you like feel weird and then you
would never do that to someone else so
she should do it to this girl so this
girl knows how it feels that's the only
way she'll learn no I like I like just
giving like just [__] lighting her up
yeah like give her a knife yeah you turn
you whip your head and you say girl you
think I don't have eyes I know you know
I've been going you know I've been
traveling this with this since my early
20s like I don't need you to tell me
every single time that you see a gray
hair because by the way we won't be able
to have other conversations because duh
I've got a lot of gray hairs coming in I
got my roots touch up every six weeks if
you can't help but say something every
time you see gray hair then I guess I
can't see you until the day I have my
root touch up and I'll see you that
afternoon good day sir [__] I said good
day
got him
got him all right our third and final is
an update so I will read her original
submission for those who remember a
little while ago um this girl wrote in
she was humiliated that she had met her
in her uh husband's extended family at a
wedding and it was going great but she
found out afterwards she had been
walking around with like a big old
period stain the entire time everyone
knew her husband didn't tell her and she
was just mortified and she didn't know
what to do
um we then told her that you know
perspective is everything change Shake
It Up the way you look maybe okay it's
not embarrassing that you had a period
stain you were flaunting your fertility
you are showing off amongst commoners
you are his wife you are going to give
him babies like it's a power move just
to change your perception you know
here's what she wrote in Jackson turd
reaching out with a very happy update I
am the toaster who unknowingly got her
period while meeting my husband's
extended family for the first time my
husband thought it was best to not tell
me and let me prance around with a
bloody stain on my dress all day which
was humiliating and I didn't share this
in my original post but getting my
period also sucked because it meant I
sadly still wasn't pregnant after trying
for almost a year well that was the last
time I got my period I got pregnant
right after that trip and I just
delivered a beautiful baby girl so now
I'm not the wife with a period stain but
rather the wife who delivered the
family's first grandchild you guys were
right I guess I was flaunting my
fertility love you too thank you for
going through this journey with me oh
man not me crying oh my God that's so
beautiful at first I was stealing bags I
was like oh you're flaunting your
fertility but she was having a hard time
getting pregnant right
um but no plot twist there's a babe now
and you know what
that's life you can't have a baby
without a period okay so next time
everyone gets a period saying oh my God
yeah I'm a human I'm a woman I'm taking
care of repopulating this Earth eat my
ass [__] what are you doing yeah what
are you doing slob sitting on the couch
eating Netflix
yeah eating Netflix you know what I mean
yeah totally love it happens nothing
turd love a toaster uh giving birth to a
baby Crouton it's everything
it really really is and now I'm sure you
missed that period and now you have your
dress you can look back on
what you could take your dress out of
the closet because you miss it
because it's stained from your period
I get it like you have like now when you
don't have your period like give your
baby like you missed like not being
pregnant yeah now you can look back on
your last period because it's right on
your dress right now you should frame it
like don't take the dress to the dry
cleaners do what Monica Lewinsky did
when you know Bill Clinton ejaculated on
her dress keep it as a momentum Memento
yeah the last time it was just the two
of us
oh yeah give it to your husband's
birthday
yes I love so romantic it's so romantic
that's everything we are Romantics turdy
and I at the end of the day we are
nothing if not hopeless Romantics
definitely we're the new Romantics come
and come along with me heartbreak
international Anthem we sing it proudly
we're too busy toasting to get knocked
off our feet
maybe where the new Romantics no I got
it the best people in life are toasty
it wasn't great the best people in life
are Steve
so much better [__] I should have just
let you do it instead of bulldozing over
you with my bad idea it's okay that's
how the collaboration process works
and maybe you need like a truly bad idea
to appreciate a good one yeah you need
to hear it wrong first so you can be
certain that what you've got is right
Jax
that's beautiful oh thank you turd and
that is also our show thank you so much
for listening to the toast the
millennial Morning Show where we deliver
the past five stories that you need to
know everybody do Friday on YouTube so
you're watching this on YouTube please
don't forget to subscribe give this
video a thumbs up
we are back to bar with our final show
of the week so make sure you head over
to patreon.com so you never miss out on
a day of content we love you dearly
dearly dearly love you
and we'll see ya tomorrow
because we love you bye